raised by wolves has been renewed for a
second season
but will still have monster ponder the
meaning of the hbo max series first
season
and its finale the beginning this is the
ending of raised by wolves explained
the finale of raised by wolves first
season makes it more clear than ever
that our heroes have been employed as
instruments of some greater will
presumably that of saul the god of the
mythic religion
throughout the series multiple
characters have had strange visions
including the androids some of these
visions seem to show the future
some are glimpses of the distant past
and summer apparitions of the dead child
tally who tumbled into one of the
gigantic bottomless pits that appear
across the surface of kepler-22b
but the will of soul becomes louder and
clearer in the first season finale as
not only do we hear his words for a
fairly cogent prophet and paul but we
also see it apparently exercise and the
goopy
wiggling flesh of the baby number seven
the beginning allows us to take stock of
how each character has been manipulated
presumably by the same supernatural
guiding hand
an orphan boy who dwells
in an empty land the prophet who will
discover the myth mysteries
throughout this first season there have
been a few candidates for who this
prophecy might refer to
and it appears that the answer may be
the most obvious one after all
paul the brilliant methodic child whose
birth parents have been dead since
before the ark even left earth has been
receiving messages from seoul that are
clearer and more frequent than anyone
else the clearest evidence that paul is
in touch with an actual omniscient being
it's his newfound knowledge of mary
sue's true nature that she is not his
mother but actually the atheist soldier
who killed and replaced her
being a bright kid it's plausible that
he may have been able to piece some of
this together but he also calls her by
her real name
which he could not have conjured by
himself unaware of paul's apparent open
channel from sul his faux father marcus
believes that he himself
is a subject of the prophecy marcus has
long since cast aside his previous
identity
as the atheist soldier caleb and is now
a true believer
and it's easy to see why when caleb
hears the voice of soul
we hear his words as clearly as caleb
does it's reasonable to assume for the
moment that the same voice is speaking
to both caleb and paul
as it has led both of them to facilitate
the birth of number seven
earlier in the first season seoul told
marcus that if he lets mother live
he will be quote king of this world this
is in line with what paul is told that
mother is carrying saul's child if
marcus is also solves instruments then
it makes sense that he would command
marcus to spare his unborn child
what further purpose marcus might serve
in seoul's design isn't clear
but as a second mythic vessel has now
arrived at kepler-22b
marcus has now found new enemies or
potentially new disciples
up until the final episode mother is
believed that her child is the will of
campion sturgis
the atheist who reprogrammed her back on
earth using the hibernation pod's
virtual reality system mother has
reassessed her archived memories of her
time with sturgis she later interacts
with a version of sturges
as she believes as an archived program
which tells her that her pregnancy is
the next step in their plan
however this no longer seems to be true
in episode 8
mass the healthcare android carl tells
mother that necromancers such as herself
were created using dark photons
based on designs decoded from within the
mythic scriptures
not even her builders fully understand
how she works but if the scriptures come
from seoul
then she is literally built from a
divine plan which may have included
constructing a biomechanical child
her true mission to create this new
being likely predates her programming by
sturgis does the version of sturges with
whom mother has a virtual encounter
actually have anything to do with the
real sturgis or is this soul taking on
the visage of the one who mother sees as
a creator in the beginning
mother describes her pregnancy we
communed in a virtual space
and while we did information was
downloaded into my drives
the question is where these files were
downloaded from
reports that kepler 22b is uninhabited
have proven to be greatly exaggerated
kepler 22b
is home not only to fossils ancient
temples and creepy galloping mammals
but to an intelligent species of
humanoids the beginning offers our first
clear encounter with one of kepler's
humanoid inhabitants their existence has
been hinted at over the course of the
season
that cave dwelling that the methraic
troops found back in episode 5 had to
belong to someone
and we caught only a quick glimpse of
its owner at the time now we've seen
their face
or at least the face of one of their
kind and the individual who tries to
knock mother into a bottomless pit
mother kills the humanoid before he can
learn any more from them but father
believes that the neanderthal skull it
carries indicates that life on
kepler-22b
is evolving in a reverse path from that
of humans on earth that's quite a leap
evolution is the result of random
mutation and long-term selection across
millennia
and it makes no sense for a species to
evolve backwards however since one of
the characters i'm raised by wolves is
essentially god we can't really take
intelligent design entirely off the
table
in any case the beginning implies that
nearly all the creatures in the show
may share a single evolutionary ladder
upon which mother's new baby now sits at
the top
of course by baby we mean four foot
floating serpent with a lamprey's more
which is as much a surprise to mother as
it is to us well she and sue have been
trying to monitor its gestation over the
past few episodes
neither of them have access to a
sonogram and while neither of them could
have predicted that mother's number
seven would be a gooey snake monster
that's borne by flying up out of her
throat
we the audience should probably have
expected something like this from the
man behind alien and prometheus
at the form of this new creature closely
resembles a form of kepler-22b's native
fossilized serpents
should be all the evidence we need that
its conception has nothing to do with
the plans of campion sturgis
number seven quickly grows to the size
of the monsters who have left their
fossils all across the planet but
creator aaron gudykaushi has already
confirmed that it had inherited
abilities from its android parent as
well although it's not for the first
time in a season finale
mother is confronted by father about the
fatalistic streak she's been developing
over the course of the story father's
position that their mission is their own
to determine
better represents atheism than mothers
which is essentially a dogmatism based
around another person's design for them
mother has always revered her creator
campion sturgis after whom she named her
youngest child there's a logic to this
as an artificial life form she has a
certainty of purpose a few humans can
ever experience
she is not only programmed to serve a
specific aim but she is conscious of
that programming
and aware of the person who created it
her feelings intensify after uncovering
archived memories of their time together
on earth during which she falls in love
and the feeling may even be reciprocated
mother may retain the capacity for faith
from her time as a methodic maid
necromancer but as she points out to
father her
effective worship of her creator does
not actually require faith
faith implies the possibility for doubt
and mother has met her god sul on the
other hand is an immaterial god who
until recently
could be dismissed a superstition it
will be interesting to see how she copes
with the strange new physical evidence
of soul's existence
that has just been born from her body
unlike mother who is an advanced weapon
of mass destruction reprogrammed to be a
parent
father is a standard service model a
run-of-the-mill android who's not
supposed to be special
and yet father is better at being a
human than anyone else living on
kepler-22b
he's a caring and attentive parent as
well as a loving partner
and he clearly has a rich inner life
mother may have physical abilities that
he lacks
but father is at least equal when it
comes to emotion and self-actualization
he won't disappoint you he's as loyal as
i come
a fine protector in the final episode
father realizes that his love for mother
and his feelings of jealousy during her
pregnancy
are putting his mission to protect the
children at risk father intends to purge
his memory files
eliminating this record of their years
together and the pain he associates with
them which is perhaps the most human
desire he's demonstrated so far
father and mother set aside their
quarrel when the birth of number seven
presents an imminent danger to their
children
and flinchingly sacrificing themselves
by piloting the lander into one of the
pits
and flying straight into the planet's
molten core with number seven aboard
their reconciliation is very speedy but
superhuman processing power seems to
mean a superior ability to get over
yourself
mother and father clearly expect the
heat and pressure of the planets in a
core to destroy their craft as our
understanding of geology
says that it should but raised by wolves
version of kepler-22b
evidently has its own special properties
that allow the lander to shoot right
through it and emerge on the opposite
side of the planet which appears to be
the tropical zone where they intended to
bring the children after number seven's
birth
since they bail from the lander and is
subsequently destroyed by one of number
seven's phenomenal growth spurts mother
and father are now stranded half a world
away from sue and the kids if not for
the arrival of the second mythia [ __ ]
near the end of the episode
there'll be no reason to expect that
mother and father could ever reunite
with the rest of the family now there's
at least hope that campion and the gang
can hijack a craft from them
and mount a rescue mission or at least
simply settled in the tropical zone as
they'd initially planned whether
piecemeal or all at once we should
expect a change in scenery in season two
since we doubt the myth react of much
interest in starting their colony in a
dry rocky desert either
the rest of the pack may not have had
much to do in the first season finale of
raised by wolves but they are the
subject of the season's parting moments
in the episode's penultimate scene we
see campion process
a gut-wrenching loss of his parents
before discovering the strength and calm
that father praised him for
in one of their final scenes together he
rejoins his family and the atmosphere
and cinematography of the scene
heavily implied that the family will now
be looking to campion to lead them
mary sue has so far survived her gunshot
wound but search your identity as an
atheist
soldier has been exposed to the family
whether this will put her at all to the
religious hunter and holly has yet to be
seen
her deception is least likely to bother
tempest who is both an ardent atheist
herself and also very pragmatic
vita the youngest has no lines in the
finale and isn't really a character yet
but she may have to grow into one next
season
paul has run off after shooting sue and
is now on his own will he discover the
new mythriaku rivals will he go off on
his own path perhaps guided by further
divine intervention
one thing's for certain when paul and
marcus run into each other next the two
are going to have a lot to talk about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one